[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 159 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform podcast.
I'm Mark Mandel,
and as always, I'm
here with my colleague,
Melanie Warrick.
How're you doing, Melanie?
MELANIE WARRICK: Hey, Mark.
I'm good.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
doing all right.
I'm hanging out in Seattle.
MELANIE WARRICK: You are,
and I'm in San Francisco.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm back.
MARK MANDEL: You're back.
MELANIE WARRICK: Where
are you at, Mark?
MARK MANDEL: I'm at KubeCon.
MELANIE WARRICK:
You're at KubeCon!
MARK MANDEL: I'm at KubeCon.
It's my first KubeCon.
I'm very excited.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's awesome.
And all the people are
there, we were saying.
We were saying, earlier
before we started recording,
all the cool people are there.
MARK MANDEL: All the
cool Kubernetes people.
There are other cool people.
There are definitely
other cool groups.
MELANIE WARRICK: There are.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, OK, Mark,
it's our end-of-year wrap-up.
It's our last episode
for the year 2018.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we're going
to go through all the stuff
that we liked about this
year and all the stuff
that everyone from our
listeners liked from this year.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
realized we probably
should have done all the things
we don't like from this year,
too, just to shake
it up a little bit.
But yes, we are going to
talk about all the top 10
and some of our favorites from
the cool things of the week.
But before we get into
that, as always, we
will do the last cool
things of the week for 2018,
and we have a question of the
week for this year, which is--
MARK MANDEL: What were your
personal highlights for 2018?
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes,
all the things 2018.
Well, great, so let's get into
the cool things of the week.
What is the cool thing of
the week for you, Mark?
MARK MANDEL: Well,
cool thing of the week
is definitely that there is
a whole stack of Googlers
a KubeCon--
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: --doing a
wide variety of things.
So there's a booth,
there are sessions,
there's workshops, some of
which will have already started
by the time this comes out.
But when this comes out, I'll
be doing mentoring sessions
on the Wednesday,
so you probably
would have missed the
one in the morning,
but you may still catch
the one in the afternoon.
I'll be speaking on Wednesday
as well about Agones,
but there's-- yeah, there's a
wide variety of Google stuff
going on, which
is pretty awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: That
MARK MANDEL: It's
my first KubeCon.
I'm very excited.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Well, how long has
this conference been going on?
MARK MANDEL: I want to
say like four years?
I could be wrong.
I could be totally wrong.
MELANIE WARRICK: I can't
believe this is your first one.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Very exciting.
MARK MANDEL: And
on that vein, there
is a blog post that
goes along with this.
There's a Kubernetes
and GKE for developers,
a year of Cloud Console.
So basically it's actually
a really nice summary
of Cloud Console that exists
for GKE and what it does.
So starting your cluster,
and then once it's
up and running, being able
to have a look inside it
and see metrics
around CPU and memory,
and what's going on internally,
and what things are running,
and then also having access
to the Cloud Marketplace
and be able to drop
things in from there.
It's just a really
cute little article
talking about all
the things you can
do in GKE that are integrated
directly into the Cloud Console
as well, which is just a
nice touch for KubeCon.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's very nice.
Another cool thing of the
week is reducing gender bias
in Google Translate.
We got an announcement
post out there
that is talking about how
Google's efforts to promote
fairness and reduce bias
in machine learning,
there's been changes
that allow Translate
to provide feminine and
masculine translations
for some gender-neutral words.
So especially
words like surgeon,
that will now be translated
from English into French
or Italian or Portuguese or
Spanish so you can get both.
And that example's
already out there,
and you can read about
it and check it out.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I like this.
It's being essentially
monolingual,
not being used to
having languages
have feminine and masculine.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's a blind spot,
and so it's really good
to see this come through.
MELANIE WARRICK: I agree.
And another thing
we wanted to mention
is a blog post that's out there
around Cloud Security Command
Center and that
it's now in beta.
And so that is out
there, it's providing
a number of new features that
include expanding coverage
across GCP services like data
store, DNS, load balancing,
Spanner, container registry,
Kubernetes engine, and Virtual
Private Cloud.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
this is great.
I love this turn of phrase,
like if you need a central place
to understand your
security posture--
[DRUM ROLL]
--which I really like,
this is the view for you.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
I heard that recently, actually,
from our colleague Jen.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Security posture.
[DRUM ROLL]
It's a good word.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: But yeah, it lets
you assess your security risks
and vulnerabilities
from a single place,
and you can see your assets
and integrate security findings
from a variety of security
leaders, including Google
themselves.
So if you're into security,
which I think we all are,
it's a great thing to check out.
MELANIE WARRICK: At
this point, especially.
It's expanded into
client libraries,
including Java, Node, and Go.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK:
You can go online,
you can see what it
provides, and see how you
would need to engage with it.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
All right, well,
why don't we go talk
about all our favorite
things from this year?
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes,
let's go talk to ourselves.
MARK MANDEL: So it's
the end of 2018.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's
our wrap-up segment.
MARK MANDEL: It is.
It's our recap episode.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yay, 2018, I can't
believe it's already the end.
MARK MANDEL: Wow, time flies.
MELANIE WARRICK: Happy holidays.
MARK MANDEL: Happy holiday.
MELANIE WARRICK: Happy
Hanukkah, happy Festivus,
happy all the things.
MARK MANDEL: Yes,
all the things.
Kwanzaa is now, too, happy that.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Whatever
you want to celebrate,
or if you don't
and you just want
to sit around and
watch Netflix all day.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Have a good one.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely do that.
That sounds great.
I'm going to do that.
MELANIE WARRICK: I just
plugged for them, too.
And we're not getting
paid by them either.
MARK MANDEL: No, excellent.
So as per tradition
of the last few years,
we like to a wrap-up
episode where
we talk about all the things
that happened in 2018.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
to start this off,
we actually want
to talk about some
of the actual podcast
accomplishments for the year.
So a couple of the
things that come to mind
are the new intro
and outro music
we get from our editors, which
we're really grateful for.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
We have a brand new website, a
company by the name of M Booth
did that for us,
and it's gorgeous.
It looks great.
MELANIE WARRICK: And we
have new YouTube videos.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we
have an internal team that
works on that now, and
they do a much better job
than we did ourselves.
MELANIE WARRICK: Definitely.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it
looks gorgeous too.
MELANIE WARRICK: And we also
have a lot of new photos
that we captured for
the year, which we've
been using, because we know many
people were saying, Melanie,
you're not Francesc.
[LAUGHTER]
Why aren't there
pictures of you?
MARK MANDEL: We had
to do a photo shoot.
It was terrible.
We had to be the
center of attention.
MELANIE WARRICK: You were
sick the whole time,oo.
MARK MANDEL: Was I?
I don't even remember.
MELANIE WARRICKL I don't
know if you remember this,
but you were really
ill at the time.
MARK MANDEL: Show must go on.
MELANIE WARRICK: But
other accomplishments
for the year, February 20 we
hit one million downloads.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
and just recently we
hit two million downloads.
MELANIE WARRICK: December 1.
MARK MANDEL: High five.
MELANIE WARRICK: High five.
[HIGH FIVE SOUND]
And Mark, you and the podcast
celebrated three years.
MARK MANDEL: Three
years, so long.
MELANIE WARRICK: And you
are never going to leave.
So yes, it's been a lot of
accomplishments this year.
MARK MANDEL: It's
been a good run.
MELANIE WARRICK: Plus,
while we're recording this,
we mentioned we are over
two million downloads.
We're at like
2,005,000 downloads.
And you'd mentioned
about one million,
1.1 million downloads
this year so far?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK:
It's pretty great.
MARK MANDEL: The trajectory of
the listenership of the podcast
has definitely been
up and to the right.
So thank you to everyone
for listening, actually.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
And thank you to all the guests.
And we're going to do our top
10, top 10 most downloaded
episodes.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, oh my god.
MELANIE WARRICK: And we
start from the top, from 10
and count down for everybody.
We've got it together today.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Anyway, so
yeah, top 10 most downloaded.
A lot of them came from
this year, actually.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I
think almost all of them.
MELANIE WARRICK: Almost all,
with the exception of one.
MARK MANDEL: All right, but
we won't tell you which one.
MELANIE WARRICK: No.
MARK MANDEL: You
have to find out.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: OK, so
number 10, starting
from the bottom or the top,
depends how you look at it,
it's fine.
One of my favorite
people, Sara Novotny,
who has come to join us, the
head of open source strategy
at Google Cloud.
I'm such a huge fan of Sarah's.
MELANIE WARRICK: Me too.
MARK MANDEL: I
really, really am.
It was such a
delight and pleasure
to spend time with her
on the podcast talking
about open source, talking
about the history of Kubernetes.
Sarah's been around since
the beginning of Kubernetes
all the way through to
the creation of CNCF.
So Sarah is just a wealth of
information about open source
and open source strategy.
It's such a privilege, actually,
to have her in our company
and being able to ask her
questions about these things
and talk to her about open
source and open source
strategy.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
It was a wonderful episode.
Our number nine episode
is from episode 130,
and these were a
couple of friends
and colleague, Juliet
Hoagland and Michelle Casbon,
joined us to talk
about data science.
So we got a chance to talk
about what is data science, what
are some of the
toolings, just some
of the challenges, the
benefits, how it's applied.
It was a great episode.
I was grateful that
we could get them on.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
and the first time,
I think, that Michelle Casbon
has been on the episode,
but she has been on a
few times since then.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, she has.
She came back to help out
with some of the wrappers
recently too, which was great.
Number eight for
most downloaded?
MARK MANDEL: Launchpad
Studio with Malika Cantor
and Peter Norvig.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
that was our first
episode of this year.
MARK MANDEL: Really?
MELANIE WARRICK: That was
our first episode this year.
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
I didn't realize that.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
I was very excited that we
got them on for this episode
in particular.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it was
a really good episode.
Launchpad Studios does a
little work with startups,
and there was this really
interesting cross-pollination
between-- they were talking
about AI startups and startup
culture and how the
technology of AI
has changed so much that it's
enabled that space to really
open up and be explored.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
they're pushed especially
to be able to make
that accessible,
those types of tooling,
machine learning in particular,
accessible to smaller groups.
So that was something that
we got a chance to dive into,
and I'm glad we were
able to have them on.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it was really good.
Number seven.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yes, number seven.
MARK MANDEL: Number seven, so
this wasn't recorded this year.
But I think it's been
around for a long time.
So this is Tim Hockin
talking about Kubernetes 1.7.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Your favorite thing.
MARK MANDEL: My favorite
thing, Kubernetes.
MELANIE WARRICK:
This was the episode
that was holding the number
one spot up until this year.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, for
a really long time.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: I think this
is testament to a couple
of things, one of which
is people love Kubernetes,
and that's great.
People also really like Tim.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: People
really like Tim.
Tim, if you're listening,
you should feel really good
about that.
I think that's
definitely something
that's kept this episode
going for such a long time
at such a high spot
in our downloads.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
The sixth most downloaded
podcast was episode number 113,
and that was with Yifei Feng.
And we were talking about
Open Source TensorFlow.
So this actually was holding our
number three spot for a while,
and it recently was unseated.
I was watching that, and I
was really impressed by it.
She got into Open Source.
She got into the
tooling in Open Source,
working with the
community, what that means
and just talking
about the challenges
and the interesting
values that you get out
of working within Open Source.
So it was great to speak
with her and have her on.
MARK MANDEL: I
really liked this one
because so often with
large Open Source projects
there's so much
automation and so many
tools that happen
behind the scenes
to make sure everything
runs in the way it supposed
to in the community and
help out all the people who
are authors and developers and
contributors and people who
provide feedback.
And I think sometimes
it gets a little hidden,
and so it was really nice
to bring it to the front
and talk about the
tooling that has
to happen for these sort
of scale of projects,
to deal with the
scale of contribution
that it's happening, and how to
manage that so that people can
do the things that they're good
at as humans and robots can do
the things that
they're good at, too.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Fifth most downloaded.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, the fifth
most downloaded is episode 128.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
MARK MANDEL:
Decision Intelligence
with Cassie Kozyrkov.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: I hope I got
your name right, Cassie.
I apologize in advance.
MELANIE WARRICK:
She's very steeped
deep into the decisions
intelligence space,
and was able to come on and
talk to us about the importance
of it, what it means, how
valuable it is in particular
in the machine
learning and AI space.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, Cassie
is the chief decision
engineer at Google Cloud.
She works a lot with
customers to basically help
them make decisions about how
their data can make decisions,
essentially.
MELANIE WARRICK: Which
is crucial for applied,
especially.
But she has a great background
with helping people understand
these complex concepts,
especially when it comes
to statistical
inference and just
other additional technological
concepts in relation
to decision intelligence.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, absolutely.
Episode number four.
MELANIE WARRICK:
MARK MANDEL: Two
wonderful teammates
of ours, Seth and Liz,
come on to battle it out
about what is better--
SRE or DevOps.
MELANIE WARRICK: Everything.
MARK MANDEL: It's a
battle of the ages.
MELANIE WARRICK: All of it, yes.
It was a throwdown.
There was a lot of blood.
It was great.
No, they have a good
video series, too,
you should check out, that we
did get into understanding SRE
and DevOps in relation
to each other,
separately, what that
means, how to approach it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
If you want to see which one
wins, you have to listen.
MELANIE WARRICK: And some of
their favorite tools and stuff.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
No, it's a great discussion
on SRE and DevOps culture.
MELANIE WARRICK: All
right, the top three.
MARK MANDEL: Top three.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So number three.
MARK MANDEL: Number three.
MELANIE WARRICK: It used
to be held by Yifei--
Jeff Dean.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Talking about Google AI.
And this was a
great episode where
we got into a number
of different subjects.
We talked about TPUs and the
history of machine learning
and AI and Google, and we
talked about parallel processing
in his research from
back in the day.
We talked about Deep
Learning Indaba,
which was a conference
he was going
to be speaking at, and just
the importance of Africa,
especially, because there was a
recent research institute that
was open there.
We got into a lot.
MARK MANDEL: We got into a lot.
Melanie, I just want to
actually say thank you
for setting this up, because
it was such a highlight
for my year, speaking to Jeff.
It was one of those
conversations I came away
with so many interesting
ideas that I didn't know
I was going to get walking in.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: And Jeff is
such an amazing person.
It really was an absolute
pleasure to talk to Jeff
and have this conversation
and learn so much, even just
being the host.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yes, I feel the same.
That was a good one for it to
be our number three in the most
downloaded.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
MELANIE WARRICK: All right.
MARK MANDEL: Number two.
MELANIE WARRICK: Number two.
Percy.io with Mike
Fotinakis, which I hope I'm
not botching that.
But anyways, Mike came on early
on in the year to talk to us,
and so a friend of
mine works there.
And that's the reason why
we were able to get this all
set up to begin with.
And for those who don't know--
MARK MANDEL: So percy.io
is a continuous integration
platform, specifically
working around visualization.
So basically how
does my site look?
Has it changed from how
it's meant to be before?
Basically a tool to be like,
is my design doing the things
that it should be doing?
Has my UX changed in a way
that I'm not anticipating?
MELANIE WARRICK: Exactly.
And the visual reviews
specifically in the CI space
is very valuable with the
way our world is working.
But this integrates
really nicely with GitHub.
MARK MANDEL: And
Mike went all the way
through how they use GCP and
infrastructure and stuff, too.
It was a super
interesting interview.
MELANIE WARRICK: It
was a great interview,
and so it's our second
most downloaded.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MELANIE WARRICK: And number one?
MARK MANDEL: Ooh, big drumroll.
[DRUM ROLL]
Here it comes.
Still holding this
spot, the spot's
actually been held
for a little while.
MELANIE WARRICK: He's been
holding it pretty much almost
since February or
March of this year.
MARK MANDEL: It is Sam Ramji.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
He was, at the time, our
VP of product management
for Google Cloud Platform.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so this is
a really lovely one as well.
Sam is a delightful
fellow as well.
MELANIE WARRICK: We got
into some of his history,
like his work at Cloud
Foundry, being chief strategy
officer for Apigee.
It was a really
fascinating conversation
because we got into
things like open source
and distributed systems
as well as philosophy.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we
talked about team culture
and basically how
people become performers
and how to treat people.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yeah, it was great.
So if you want to
check out that episode
and you haven't already--
MARK MANDEL: And Sam,
if you're listening,
I hope you're proud
of this episode.
MELANIE WARRICK: I hope
all is going well for you.
MARK MANDEL: Indeed,
indeed, indeed.
MELANIE WARRICK:
We were also going
to mention what our top
10 were for this year,
not for all time.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: But
we're going to just make
a side note about this.
It's pretty much the same list--
MARK MANDEL: It is.
MELANIE WARRICK:
--with one exception.
MARK MANDEL: What's
the exception?
MELANIE WARRICK:
The exception is
that instead of
Tim Hockin's being
in number seven, because it was
recorded in a previous year,
we actually have one
of the other episodes
that we recorded this
year that popped up,
which is Project Jupyter.
MARK MANDEL: Oh yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: And that was
recorded with Jessica Forde,
Yuvi Panda, and Chris Holdgraf.
So they were all members of
Project Jupyter, working on it.
They came on to talk
to us about what it is,
the various products and
services that are provided.
This is a tool that's
very popular, especially
in the data space, and we
had some good conversations,
especially around
reproducibility,
some of the bigger
challenges in the data space
and how Project Jupyter is
working on addressing those.
MARK MANDEL: Also the
most number of guests
we've ever fit inside a podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: That is
the most number of guests.
I know, you're like, wait,
there's too many people.
MARK MANDEL: There's
too many people.
MELANIE WARRICK: We don't
have this many mics.
No, we made it work.
And we also talked about
distributed computing
and Kubernetes, too, which is
always one of your favorites.
MARK MANDEL: Always,
always, always.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's a lot.
MARK MANDEL: That's a lot.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Maybe we're done.
Are we done?
MARK MANDEL: No.
So I want to also
talk a little bit
about each other's
favorite episodes.
We did a lot of
episodes this year.
We do one a week.
MELANIE WARRICK: We did.
MARK MANDEL: It was
like 50 episodes.
MELANIE WARRICK: And I
had a really hard time
picking my top favorites.
MARK MANDEL: I know.
I think we should be
proud of ourselves.
I think we did some
really good work.
MELANIE WARRICK: We did
do good work this year.
MARK MANDEL: So let's go
backwards and forwards.
What was one of your
favorites, Melanie?
MELANIE WARRICK: A
highlight for me this year
was when we got to interview
Dr. Fei-Fei Li about Cloud AI.
And she used to be the
chief scientist of AI and ML
at Google, and she's returned to
being professor at the Computer
Science Department at Stanford.
So that episode, we had to
literally squeeze that one in.
We barely got that in time.
I wanted to release
that for the week
when it was International
Women's Day.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MELANIE WARRICK: And so we
talked to her about the work
that she was doing at the time
to make AI accessible on GCP,
as well as we talked about
her research in health care
with AI.
So that was a great episode.
MARK MANDEL: That
was a great episode.
I'm also trying
to avoid episodes
we've mentioned previously,
because they're all
amazing episodes.
Otherwise I'll just
gush about Sarah
Novotny for an hour which--
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: --is
probably not that useful.
But a highlight for me,
definitely developer relations
that we did with Mandy Waite.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Mandy is great.
She's been in the
developer relations game
and also here at Google
for a really long time
and just brings a
wealth of experience
about developer relations
and why it's important
and the team itself
here at Google Cloud.
So it was an absolute pleasure
to spend some time with her.
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm glad
we got her on, for sure.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, and just talk
through all that kind of stuff.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Another highlight
for me was when we got
Timnit Gebru and Margaret
Mitchell, who are
researchers here
at Google, on the podcast--
and at the time, actually,
Timnit was not here,
she was at Microsoft,
but we got them on
to talk about machine
learning bias and fairness.
MARK MANDEL: Such
a good episode.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
We didn't even have to work
that hard for that one,
because the two
of them knew what
needed to be talked about
around machine learning
bias and fairness, and
they just went with it.
Yeah, you know, if you want
to understand that space
and understand some of the
challenges in the space
as well as the work that's being
done from a social side as well
as an algorithmic side,
they both covered it.
We have a number of resources we
included in that episode's show
notes.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah, it was--
I was really glad we
got that one together.
MARK MANDEL: That's great.
No, I love that episode too.
I wanted to put that
in my list as well.
But you set it up
so you can have it.
MELANIE WARRICK: I took it.
MARK MANDEL: You can take it.
MELANIE WARRICK: I mentioned it.
It's both of our favorites.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Contributing to Kubernetes--
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: --with Paris
Pittman and Garret Rodrigues,
just talking through the
contributor experience
and how that gets managed and
how they do special interest
groups at Kubernetes.
Kubernetes is such a
large open source project,
so having an understanding
of how the community works
was super interesting
to hear about.
And I know there's
a lot of people
who are interested
in getting involved,
and there's so many areas
in which to get involved,
so I hope that was a valuable
resource to everyone who
listened.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And you got to touch
on one of your favorite topics.
MARK MANDEL: Kubernetes.
MELANIE WARRICK: Kubernetes.
MARK MANDEL: Who knew that?
Nobody knew that.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah, it was
good to have them on, for sure.
I want to put them
all on the top here,
but another highlight
for me was talking
to Harben Girma,
who came on to talk
about accessibility and tech.
We were able to capture
that podcast in particular
because she spoke at Next.
And so she came on, and
she was able to talk
through some of the importance
of accessibility in tech.
She's the first
deaf-blind person
to graduate from Harvard
Law, and she specifically
advocates for
equal opportunities
for people with disabilities.
And so this is something
she was able to speak
very in-depth about.
MARK MANDEL: It was an
absolute pleasure, absolutely.
I agree 100%.
MELANIE WARRICK: Another
highlight for you?
MARK MANDEL: This is
another highlight for me.
This one I really liked.
It's the first person
who's been able to do
a demo on the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Actions on
Google with Mandy Chan.
So talking about voice
actions and all the technology
that comes behind voice
actions, and because we're
an audio-only podcast, Mandy
could make an actual demo
happen, which was awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
remember that day.
You were like, let's try
this other thing out.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it was so much fun.
It was such a delight
having her on, and again,
another episode where I
walked away and I was like,
I need to play with this.
I want to do games
with voices and stuff.
This is cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
her energy about it
is very infectious, too.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so infectious.
Mandy's great.
Thank you very much for
coming on the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
Another highlight
for me was talking
with Raia Hadsell about robotics
navigation and reinforcement
learning.
We were getting
that one on the fly.
That was one of those
that we, thankfully, were
able to put into our schedule.
And the way she
covers these topics
was very helpful and
insightful and useful.
So if you want to hear more
about just the advances
in the field, about
robotics learning
to navigate new
surroundings, she
talked specifically about
her research on that recently
and how machine
learning is just,
in essence, helping us to
better understand our minds.
MARK MANDEL: Another
the highlight for me--
oh, there's a lot.
We should probably draw
a line at some point.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
MARK MANDEL: But I wanted
to mention this one,
because it's important.
They're all important.
But Wellio with Sivan
Aldor-Noiman and Erik Andrejko.
I've messed that up.
I'm sorry, Erik.
But this is a wonderful
practical example
of how to apply AI in machine
learning to a particular thing.
So Wellio is a platform that
is an intelligent platform
to help people with
shopping, planning, preparing
food, and enjoying
healthy meals,
and doing it in a way
that basically adapts
for the users of the system,
which is just amazing, first
of all, but hugely complicated
and just so interesting.
And so they also
break down their usage
of Google Cloud and the
technologies they use
and how they go about it.
It was super practical.
MELANIE WARRICK: What I
appreciated most about
that episode was that they took
us through the full pipeline.
It was from literally
the data to the
putting it into production.
It's a nice, full picture
of how you deal with,
especially machine learning,
from the start to the finish.
Another highlight for me--
I know this is a
highlight for you, too.
We got our friend KF to
come onto the podcast.
[LAUGHTER]
This was something--
MARK MANDEL: Such a
delightful episode.
MELANIE WARRICK: It
was a great episode.
We talked about Strange Loop,
which is the conference where
we all met.
We talked about remote work.
We talked about
distributed computing.
We talked about new people
getting into the field
and what that's like.
MARK MANDEL: We talked about
how KF likes to make fun of me.
MELANIE WARRICK: We
did talk about how
KF likes to make fun of you.
I know it was an episode where--
it's funny because I really
wanted her to come
on the podcast,
and she initially was a
little resistant to it.
And then when she finally
committed to doing it,
Mark was also resistant
to it because he
knew she'd make fun of him.
[LAUGHTER]
I also recognize she has a
significant amount of insights
that I'm very grateful for.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, agreed.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
I was glad we were
able to capture that episode.
So if you want to
see us having a fun
time with a friend of ours--
or hear us having a fun
time with a friend of ours,
you should listen to
the episode number 150.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
was going to say,
I got to mention one
more highlight for me.
MARK MANDEL: Go on then.
MELANIE WARRICK: The
highlight in particular
is that I went to South Africa
and captured the Deep Learning
Indaba episode.
MARK MANDEL: Great episodes.
MELANIE WARRICK: So there's
multiple ones, all of them
have their own
different values, but I
was glad I was able
to make that work
and get that on the
podcast this year.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
All right.
MARK MANDEL: Plenty of stuff
to listen to if you haven't.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know,
it's like, basically,
listen to everything this year.
MARK MANDEL: All this
stuff, just all of it.
It's all good.
All right, so let's
change track a little.
Why don't we talk about
our favorite announcements,
products, things that have
happened inside Google Cloud
that you thought
were particularly
cool and interesting, like
highlights for you for 2018?
MELANIE WARRICK: Sure.
MARK MANDEL: I'll jump in first.
So for me, I think--
I do stuff in the
games industry,
so pretty excited about
the Unity and Google Cloud
strategic alliance.
Pretty excited about that
announcement coming out.
I think there's still some
stuff coming out of that
and what's going on.
But the fact that we're
working so closely
with a company like Unity
and the Unity engine,
I think there are some really
exciting things coming down
the pipe.
And we've started talking about
it at Unite Berlin and Unite LA
about projects like Open Match,
the open source matchmaking
platform.
That also comes out this
year and the work that's
happening between Unity
and Us and Them as well as
some of the planned product
integrations coming forward
too, so pretty excited about
the whole connected games
platform--
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: --that we've
been talking about there.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Another highlight for me
that just came into my
mind is the TPUs in beta,
being able to access the TPU
chips and run your programs.
I know when they
were in alpha you
had to go through an
application process,
but in beta it made it
much more accessible
those who are doing research
and wanted to leverage those
with their TensorFlow code.
Another cool thing that
was a highlight for us
for this year, the Google
dataset search in beta as well.
Data is always a key thing you
need for any kind of machine
learning you're doing.
So having the ability to
more easily find data sets
that you can work with
and you can experiment on,
that was very much needed.
MARK MANDEL: I think
I'm going to be
on the game's broken record
for a bit-- broken record
for a bit-- broken
record for a bit.
MELANIE WARRICK: Do it.
MARK MANDEL: The recent
Halloween multiplayer Doodle
that worked with Open Match
and worked all on Google Cloud
was kind of A, just a
really cool game, but B,
also just a wonderful
demonstration of scale.
So Google Cloud, we served
over 100 million players,
60 countries, current user load
of over half a million players
during a five-minute
window at its peak.
We supported a
Google Doodle, like,
that's the Google homepage.
MELANIE WARRICK: That is cool.
MARK MANDEL: That's really cool.
So I just-- I love it,
and it was so much fun.
I love that game.
MELANIE WARRICK: A highlight
that I picked up on from Next
in particular was
the GKE On Prem.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: So many
people were excited about that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, the
possibilities for hybrid cloud,
I think, are really exciting.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Kind of
endless in some ways.
MELANIE WARRICK: It is all about
hybrid cloud at this point.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, GKE On
Prem is really exciting.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: I think in general,
also, just the updates that
continue to roll out
about Kubernetes,
unsurprisingly for me, and
then flowing into GKE as well.
You know, we're up to Kubernetes
about 1.12, off the top
my head--
I don't think 13's come out
yet-- and seeing more and more
features continue
to grow and continue
to evolve in that space.
And the things that come
on top of them as well.
I mean, we've seen things like
Knative get released this year,
Skaffold, Istio has more
updates with 1.0 this year,
gVisor as well, all
working in this sort
of containerized
cloud native space
that I think is just kind
of growing incredibly.
MELANIE WARRICK: And I
was also very excited
when I saw the news that
Google AI was opening up
another research group
out of Accra, Ghana.
So that was another highlight
for me for this year.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Actually,
we spoke about Next just
briefly before, but just
talking about Next in general.
Next for me was a highlight that
I think is worth talking about.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Next was insane.
It was great.
It was just-- there
was so much going on.
MARK MANDEL: There
It's the biggest event I've
ever seen for Google Cloud.
The amount of investment there
and the amount of production.
and the amount of announcements.
MELANIE WARRICK: There's a lot.
MARK MANDEL: And
customers-- oh my!
MELANIE WARRICK:
And then you and I
recorded like 18 interviews.
MARK MANDEL: I don't even
know how we survived.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
MARK MANDEL: I'm just linking
through to the blog post,
where it's 105 announcements
from Google Cloud Next.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: We were in like
three or four buildings.
It was, like, wow.
MELANIE WARRICK: There
was a lot going on.
And they're going to do it
all over again in April.
MARK MANDEL: That's very close.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's a
lot sooner than we think.
We should definitely sleep
for the next couple weeks.
MARK MANDEL: Oh my, yeah,
that's coming up soon, too.
Yeah, and you spoke
about a little--
just doing stuff on the
floor and recording so much.
It's such a delight to meet
our listeners and physically
see them in the
same place and be
able to talk to them and stuff.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
I was pleasantly surprised by
how many people came in just
to tell us thank you.
That was really nice.
And I listen to you
while I wash my dishes.
I listen to you while I run.
It was really cool.
MARK MANDEL: And you
got everyone chocolate.
MELANIE WARRICK: I did
get everyone chocolate,
and I was shocked by how many
people wanted our T-shirts.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: Because that
last day, there was a line.
There was an actual line.
I was like, do you guys even
know what you're lining up for?
MARK MANDEL:
T-shirts, preferably.
MELANIE WARRICK: They
didn't care, at one point,
when we didn't have
the sizes anymore
that people could choose from.
They just took whatever we had.
So that was nice.
That was really nice
and a fun experience.
Because when you're
in a booth like this
and you're just talking and
it's like, you and your head--
MARK MANDEL: It's
just us two in a room.
MELANIE WARRICK:
You're just like, eh,
whatever, we're going
to publish those,
I don't know that
anybody's listening.
And then you're like, oh no.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, no,
I really especially
loved hearing the stories
of people who were like,
I wasn't going to come to Next,
but I listen to the podcast
and now I'm here,
or we started using
GCP because of the podcast
or things like that.
MELANIE WARRICK: A lot
of people have also
said how helpful
it is for them just
to have an
understanding of basic,
here's how we go about
approaching GCP to begin with.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: So.
Thank you.
All right, Mark, I
think that covers it
in terms of at least
the top 10 highlights
and our highlights and
all the highlights,
all the fun stuff for the year.
I've really enjoyed
being on the podcast.
MARK MANDEL: I've really enjoyed
having you on the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: I am going
to tell everyone at this point
that I am actually going to be
leaving the podcast next year.
MARK MANDEL: Very sad.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
[SAD MUSIC]
It has been fun.
I'm really glad
I got to do this.
We are working on getting other
people who will be coming on.
We're actually going to change
it up a little bit next year.
So this is not going away.
There's more to come,
and you will find out
more about that later.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we'll have
some pretty good announcements,
I think, pretty
exciting announcements
for 2018 for the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So
definitely stay tuned.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah,
thanks, everybody,
for embracing me as being
your second co-host,
considering Francesc
was such an amazing one.
Big shoes to fill.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, but both
a delight and a pleasure.
MELANIE WARRICK: Same.
MARK MANDEL: You are
always welcome back.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Always,
always, always.
Do we thank ourselves
on the way out?
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARRICK: I was
just thinking that.
Well, thank you,
Mark and Melanie,
for coming on the show.
[RECORDED APPLAUSE]
MARK MANDEL: Yes, you did
an excellent job, well done.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes,
well done, well done, us.
So anyway, Mark?
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: Last
question for the year.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: Which is what
was your personal highlights
for 2018?
MARK MANDEL: Personal
highlights for 2018.
For me, I think
starting the project
at Agones, that's been a
really big thing for me.
I'm really excited
about it and working
with the people I
am working with,
and the contributors
that come on board,
and working with
Ubisoft, and just helping
build that as a
community, and the product
has been super rewarding.
I'm just amazed
at how that's been
going, so super, super excited.
MELANIE WARRICK: What would
you say is your favorite part
about all of that?
What gets you the
most excited about it?
MARK MANDEL: Actually, I
think, for me, actually, it
is the interaction
with the community.
It's when somebody comes
on board and they're like,
I built a thing or
here's a pull request.
It's such a lovely
feeling when someone's
like, you did a
thing, and I like it,
and also, here's a thing
I'm giving you back.
And you're like,
oh my god, we're
going to build things together.
And I just love
that collaboration.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Other cool things?
MARK MANDEL: Other cool things.
I love the new website.
Francesc and I did--
I think, actually
Francesc did most of it,
but did a great job, or
the best job we could,
given the resources we had--
MELANIE WARRICK: You all
did great, having something
out there, yes.
MARK MANDEL: It is
really great to have
a-- what I would refer to
as a professional website
for the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: It is gorgeous.
I really like it.
And we have working
search functionality, too,
which is super nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know,
the search is the best.
It makes it so much easier to
find content that you really
want to look at.
MARK MANDEL: And it's
pretty, it's really pretty.
MELANIE WARRICK: It is pretty.
MARK MANDEL: Which
I really like too.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great photos.
We got some great
images from James,
who's over at HD Interactive.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, who does
all the graphic design for all
the pictures that show up.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: It makes it a
really nice visual experience.
[TWINKLING SOUND]
What have been your
personal highlights?
MELANIE WARRICK: I
really enjoyed the fact
that we got to
bring Francesc back,
especially when he came back
to talk about Agones while we
were at Next.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
that was great fun.
That was really good.
MELANIE WARRICK: It was fun.
MARK MANDEL: It's always
good to bring Francesc back.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And then another
highlight for me for the
year was meeting Grace,
who was on our solution
architects podcast--
I'm totally picking
favorites, but it's true.
It was such a
pleasure to meet her,
and now I'm like, I can't
spend enough time hanging out
with her and talking
about chocolate,
clearly, so I'm glad
that Grace Mollison was
able to come on and talk
to us about Solution
Architects with Miles--
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: --at the time.
That was definitely
a highlight for me,
out of all the other highlights
that we have mentioned.
MARK MANDEL: Out of all
the other highlights.
MELANIE WARRICK: We've had a lot
of highlights in this episode.
MARK MANDEL: I would say it
would be very remiss if I
didn't mention it, but
a highlight for me,
definitely, is having you
join me on the podcast.
[SAD MUSIC]
MELANIE WARRICK: Thanks, Mark.
It has been a fun time
being on this podcast.
I'm really glad that we
were able to do this.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It's been an absolute
delight and a pleasure.
I cannot think of anyone I would
not have rather spent this year
with.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank
you, same here, sort of.
[RECORD SCRATCH]
[LAUGHTER]
No, it was good.
I'm really glad we
were able to do this.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Last
but not least for us
is, where's everyone
going to be?
It's the holidays.
So you won't see me next year,
but you will see Mark again
in 2019, and see, by--
MARK MANDEL: Hear.
MELANIE WARRICK: --meaning
listen, he'll be back.
And everybody else, hopefully,
is having a good holiday.
We want to thank a
number of people.
We definitely want
to thank our guests.
We also want to
thank Jennifer, who
has helped us stay organized
and scheduled and on top
of a number of things
that we have not been
able to be on top of at times.
We also want to thank HD
Interactive, especially
James, who has done
some phenomenal work
with our editing and our visuals
and Trae and Sabrina and Sean
as well, who've done a lot of
work around our web presence
and so forth.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks
to Greg, Greg Wilson,
glorious leader of Dev Rel
for basically supporting
the podcast
throughout everything
that's been going on.
Also thanks out
to Neil and Chuck,
who work on our marketing,
Shana, who works on social.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: They're
hugely, hugely supportive
of the podcast.
They do a huge amount of work.
MELANIE WARRICK: We also want
to thank M Booth for the website
and the overhaul of the
social media support,
and last but not
least, we want to thank
Francesc, because we
have to thank Francesc
because he's out there.
[SINISTER MUSIC]
His presence is somewhere.
MARK MANDEL: Also,
he gets really mad
if you don't mention him.
[ROAR]
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
MARK MANDEL: But
yes, without Francesc
this would not have happened
as well in the first place.
MELANIE WARRICK: It
wouldn't have started, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
MELANIE WARRICK: Mark, I
think that's it for us.
Thank you again, very much.
It has been a great experience.
And I'm really glad you and I
got to work together this year.
MARK MANDEL: Me too.
Thank you to you, and
thank you to everyone
for listening as well.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: It's been great
having listeners and getting
emails and messages on Twitter
and all that good stuff.
MELANIE WARRICK: Happy
New Year, Happy Holidays.
MARK MANDEL: All
that good stuff.
So we'll see you all in January
at some point next year,
so stay tuned.
MELANIE WARRICK: More to come.
MARK MANDEL: And yeah,
we'll see you all next year.
[MUSIC PLAYING]